mitch keller last sunday
in chicago three innings three runs
allowed
his last start here at pnc six no hit
innings
wilson contreras does the catching for
the cubs he's coming up
how long does it take oh he offered
there looked like yeah
he comes back and gets him first out i
should say because he jumped out in
front thanks to a couple foul balls
yep and the slider doesn't want to leave
it up there
that wasn't by design i don't believe
throwing the slider up above the belt
but
contreras tied up
offers at it chris bryant right hand
hitter
that ball's hit pretty well out towards
left center field that's gonna find some
space that'll take a hop
and bang off the top of the wall half
around third ian towards the plate he's
in to score
chris bryant stays hot his sixth extra
base head of the young season
and it puts the cubs on the board one to
nothing
well this is a continuing theme chris
bryant has been pretty aggressive this
year he's been taking a hack at that
first pitch
quite often and this one's right there
belt high for him
when he stays through he stays extended
and long through the strike zone
and now jack peterson
here you go foul tip oh peterson no i
didn't
you could hear him it looked as though
he actually swung but
the home plate up by will little calls
it a foul tip for a strikeout
to end the top of the first well that'll
be it
you're right that's uh gonna fall on
deaf ears so
the cubs get one and the pirates come to
bat
yeah here's zach davies zach is 28 years
old
six foot even a buck 80.
in the air center field right center
field that's jason hayward
brian reynolds reynolds hitting 240. try
to respect that change up a little bit
not there nope strikeout swing and a
miss and davey's able to get him one
two three early on the cubs lead one
number
eric gonzalez two hits in 17 at bats was
a pinch hitter
on thursday and struck out
hard hit to center field sending half
back to the track
and off his glove
so moran had rounded second now he'll
stop at third
that was a wallop by eric gonzalez
and look that just about everything and
again
when you don't see polanco even flinch
yes the one he
maybe started his hands a little bit but
that means he's
he's seeing it there's a great shot the
previous pitch that got it to 3-0
if you saw that he's shaking his head
nope nope
not touching that now stallings
line drive good at bad indeed
stallings not only ties it but gives the
pirates the lead with a two-run
single little bobble in left moran and
gonzalez score polanco to third
three to six on the fielder's choice
frasier the batter here's the pitch
and it's swinging a little poke out to
right that's going to be fair toward the
corner
frazier comes through here's polanco in
the score
keller gets to third it's a two-out rbi
double for frazier the pirates lead it
three to one
he's had some big hits this year already
that's the same ball he hit
in the first inning but he hit it just a
little bit higher
the line drive right at rizzo that's a
line drive right over rizzo's head
well frazier has had a number of two out
rbi hits this year
he hits this guy well that was a change
up
he was right on it see that's that goes
to
frazier's approach
call four reynolds will come up with the
bases loaded
[Applause]
hard to left center field over is half
and that splits the gap
bounces over the wall for a book rule
double but reynolds and the pirates will
take it
and they take a 5-1 lead in the second
inning
again those are big at bats it's
unfortunate that ball ends up bouncing
over the wall or otherwise that scores
three easily but reynolds you want to
talk about
a good approach once again look away hit
it away
all over that that's a good pitch from
davies
outside corner at the knees reynolds no
stride
staying back staying inside oh it's
pretty to watch yeah
and then look how far that carries
that's out of a lot of ballparks
towards that 410 marker help
moran second and third
and a line drive and moran with a base
hit to right core waves home reynolds
throw from hayward safe
colin moran a two-run single and they do
max out
seven one pirates in the second inning
again
great at back two out lightning here
for the pirates marin
being patient gets that change up that
was elevated a bit
hooks it into right watch the jump by
reynolds by the way everything was just
on time
perfect timing for reynolds as far as
you know that foots down as that ball is
put in play
he's off to the races had a good turn
around third base
look how close that play is two reasons
why
reynolds is in there safely the jump at
second to turn at third
probably shaved off good maybe five to
ten feet
peterson
five strikeouts for keller
base runner for jason hayward
oh 98 looking confident
six strikeouts 7-1 lead for mitch keller
the pirates
this is wilson contreras
stay hard like it five got him swinging
one more time
big second out seven punch-outs and now
rizzo
the fly ball to left reynolds there
that ball playing some tricks with that
wind
mitch keller five innings complete
lead 7-1 i guess he's gonna be satisfied
with that five-inning stint
very happy telling keller way to go
get him out of there and make him feel
good about it
one out in the bottom of the six
phillip evans
hammers this towards center field
sending hat back to the track
and phillip evans clear the deck with a
cannonball to center
his third home run of the season
[Applause]
fireworks go 8-1 pirates
that's real power right there i mean
that's a fastball inner half he just
pulls the hand and
talked pregame about phillip evans
staying inside the ball
watch where this pitch is i mean that's
in her third and up and he's hitting
that at the center field
i mean that that's not easy to do folks
that's crazy wow
and the ball hasn't been carrying at all
night yeah
two down here's jack peterson
2-2
popped in the air shallow left long run
evans fair ball
in to score is contreras and the cubs
get a run back
it's 8-2 jack will take it one more out
to get
it's ian hat high
pop to right polanco
and raise the jolly roger the pirates
get
the first home win in their second home
game